when you are thirteen and a half years
old you need to be learning negative
numbers when you are 14 you need to be
learning exponent that's silly
you need to be learning exponents once
you really understand multiplication and
you didn't be learning a negative
numbers once you really understand the
number line once you get rid of the
stigman you open it up and everyone's a
learner and everyone's just on the same
playing field it actually is empowering
for everyone I have a two-year-old son
Imran and and and obviously I care about
what his academic experience is going to
look like and I'm hoping that when he's
five or six she goes to a classroom that
not only has five or six year olds in it
but it has kids of all ages in that one
classrooms kind of a reversion back to
the one-room schoolhouse and when he
goes to that classroom some part of his
day and I'm not talking about the whole
day maybe twenty to thirty minutes of
the day especially for the core subjects
are spent on the Khan Academy watching
videos and by that time it won't just be
mathematics and science it'll be grammar
it'll be vocabulary of this orange line
he starts at the most basic concept he
doesn't move on to more advanced
concepts until he shows that he is a
hundred and ten percent proficient it's
the more basic ones and then it moves
him on and he gets data and he gets
feedback and his teachers get the exact
and the paradigm is all of these
students at all different ages they're
all gonna be working at their own pace
in every class in grammar and
mathematics and everything the teacher
now instead of having to give this
one-size-fits-all lecture to everybody
can now look at the data and see where
every student is and the software
identifies who's stuck the teacher every
now and then will sit next to em Ron and
help him Ron as a mentor actually had
that human interaction and even better
if the teacher is in Toronto even if the
teacher is around it might be better for
him Ron to be tutored by one of his
peers maybe another six year old maybe a
ten year old who was a little ahead of
the curve who's well respected as a
teacher already I mean what's really
exciting about this is an interactive
experience i cringe at the idea of my
son in a room at the same rooms that i
used to sit in sitting like this staying
at the clock waiting for the bell to
ring I don't want him to do that for 12
years I want him interacting with his
peers I want him teaching his peers I
want my son to be respected in his
classroom not because he's he got a
perfect on his SATs not because he's
he's the smartest kid in the class I
want him to be respected because he's
the best teacher in the class
because he communicates well because he
has empathy for his peers because he's
always willing to stop what he's doing
to help one of his friends I think if
that happens and I wouldn't worry too
much about what what what my son does
afterwards